[Musique]
yannick rousselet bonsoir bonsoir vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet
s'appelle singer view est ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succinctement
alors je suis yannick rousselet je suis
originaire de cherbourg je vis toujours
agir bon là haut dans le cotentin à 18
kilomètres de l'usiné de la hague 15 km
de flamanville et donc j'ai 59 ans et je
suis marié j'ai quatre enfants et voilà
je suis permanent de greenpeace france
depuis mars 2002 vous avez fait quoi
avant alors avant je travaillais à
l'arsenal de cherbourg c'est à dire que
comme tout bon cherbourgeois qui se
respecte comme mon grand père mes oncles
et ses bains j'ai fait ce qu'on appelait
à l'époque les apprentis de la marine
c'était une école d'apprentissage je
suis donc devenu ouvrier chaudronnier
elle d'abord donc pour fabriquer des
sous marins sous marins nucléaires à
cherbourg en fait il ya une espèce de
mono industrie total c'est à dire qu'on
travaille pour une clé on travaille pour
lutter à militaire où les militaires et
naturellement quand j'avais 14 ans la
famille ne pensait qu'à une chose c'est
que tous les enfants rentrent comme tous
les autres donc à la dcn à l'époque des
ctc aïn et donc pour contrôler souvent
donc j'aborde avoir été chaudronnier et
puis au bout d'un an j'ai trouvé que
c'était un peu voilà au bout rions un
peu compliqué donc je retourne à l'école
pour devenir technicien et je finis
technicien supérieur donc à ce jour
l'école de la marine alors voilà
toujours en interne c'est à dire qu'il y
avait encore tout ce qui était la
promotion interne comme on appelait ça
ce qui m'a permis donc de de faire des
formations supplémentaires donc j'ai
fini pour assimiler à des bureaux
d'études sur l'étude de forme de sous
marins en 2002 donc j'ai quitté là pour
aller au g2 irait au bout de mon
engagement
pis c'est quoi greenpeace alors je ne
puis c'est l'association qui était en 71
à la base laden de greenpeace c'est
vraiment la lutte contre le nucléaire
militaire c'est à dire que en fait il y
avait des couacs earth qui militait
contre les essais nucléaires américains
depuis plusieurs années déjà il essayé
de s'opposer à ces essais mais
finalement personne n'en parlait et puis
un des gens qui ont été
voilà coup sans vie mais en fait c'est
parce que personne ne le sait et il faut
que ça se sache et j'en ai eu l'idée
donc deux parties avec un bateau sur
lequel ils ont embarqué pour la première
fois un journaliste et qui a permis de
faire connaître leur campagne contre les
essais nucléaires sur l'île d'amchitka
la première ambition a été un échec
puisque quand ils sont arrivés la bombe
nucléaire avait déjà explosé mais
c'était un succès politique au sens
noble du terme par extrêmement fort
puisque ça a permis de créer la
polémique à terre avec les quantités de
soutien de milliers de personnes qui se
sont mis à soutenir donc le
démarche d'empêcher les essais
nucléaires ces campagnes contre le
nucléaire ont continué donc chez
greenpeace après c'est resté donc
permanent et le nom c'est venu du
premier bateau qu'il avait baptisé weill
pis donc à la paix verte est donc levé
puis cédé donc en 70 après
progressivement sont venus d'autres
idées telles que la protection des
baleines et après évidemment il ya eu
des discussions internes ce que la
priorité c'est d'abord contre le
nucléaire militaire ou est ce que c'est
d'être pour la protection des baleines
et puis finalement il ya eu une
organisation qui est devenu
international donc à la base c'était à
vancouver et puis après il ya eu des
bureaux ouverts dans d'autres endroits
aujourd'hui je comprends à 52 bureaux
dans le monde dont des bureaux
non nazis des bureaux en afrique que
bureaux en russie ses finances et
comment greenpeace la totalité de nos
dons sont des dons donc de deux
indépendants de gens qui sont adhérents
qui sont des gens qui décident de donner
de l'argent à l'organisation
loin de là les limites on va dire qu'on
a entendu très souvent alors
généralement quand on se bat contre lui
claire en france par exemple on dit
qu'il est payé pour leur part les
pétroliers quand on est en norvège et
condé sur une campagne baleines dites ce
que vous faites une super ce formidable
est ce que vous faites sur sur les
fossiles et des énergies fossiles c'est
formidable mais nous emmerder pas avec
les baleines quand on et voilà suivant
les intérêts de chacun des pays
évidemment on est forcément payé par
désaltérer concurrence est toujours ce
que ce qu'on entend et puis quelques
fois on était fiancé
ou manipulé par la cia lorsqu'on faisait
des choses en russie comme c'était aux
états unis et l inverse on a toujours
connu ça la réalité c'est que donc on
refuse les dons qui viennent de regagner
de commandes d'institutions au public un
détention privée ni public le pas de
subventions privées du compte qu'une
subvention qu'ils puissent venir de
l'entreprise alors la différence
d'ailleurs de notre organisation c'est
ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui de
pouvoir avoir une vraie indépendance sur
de pailhères de lutter c'est quoi le
budget d'une piste le budget de
greenpeace france cette année je pense
que c'est de l'ordre de 20 millions
190 mille adhérents à peu près 1 190
mille adhérents cette année je pense à
peu près et à peu près donc 20 millions
d'euros de budget en france j'ai pas en
tête le budget internationale à la
presse est proportionnel très souvent va
à ce qui est la taille de l'organisation
dans le pays c'est bon le nombre
d'adhérents aux états unis mois voilà
huit cent cinquante mille adhérents
voilà il ya des fois des petits pays
mais qui ont beaucoup d'adhérents la
france était toujours historiquement
plutôt à un petit pays de greenpeace
historiquement pendant très très
longtemps on a vivoté on va dire est
sous perfusion un petit peu des deux
financière qui venait de l'organisation
des autres pays et puis le train
dépendance financière est vraiment
arrivé qu'à la fin des années 90 où là
clairement la crise de gm la vache folle
enfin toutes ces questions qui sont
tombées sur la table plus ils volonté de
développement du directeur qui est
arrivé à cette époque là on fait qu'il
ya eu vraiment tout d'un coup vraiment
une croissance qui ne s'arrête pas
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que malgré
qu'on ait vu des organisations d'autres
associations qui est des difficultés à
cause de certaines crises je pense à la
crise de l'arc par exemple on n'a pas vu
ça il ya eu une petite inflexion mais la
croissance globale on va dire de
l'organisation le soutien des gens
continuent combien ça gagne permanent
comme vous chez greenpeace a coûté
saisie a pas de secret moi c'était
simplement quand je suis arrivé de dire
que j'avais ma ma vie familiale j'ai
tout ça et donc j'ai juste pris la paye
que j'avais à l'époque quand tu es en
bas ça serait bien que la même chose et
donc aujourd'hui j'ai 2800 euros par
mois net ce qui correspond
haut de l'échelle on va dire entre
gilbert dans l'organisation puisque je
suis dans les vieux entre guillemets je
crois que mes plus mes collègues ils ont
tous 30 35 ans et c'est super agréable
de recettes déjà ils n'ont pas
aujourd'hui encore ce niveau de salaire
de le seigneur le plus chez greenpeace
france et greenpeace alors combien je
sais simplement j'ai pas en tête le
chiffre exact du directeur je sais
simplement que il a été décidé de
respecter le 1/4 donc contredire le
salaire le plus faible ces 10 acteurs
d'ailleurs si on regarde le ce que gagne
le directeur aujourd'hui je sais que tu
as rapport toute organisation c'est
faible parce que deux c'est l'été nous
non mais disons que je pense on voit
bien à disons qu'aujourd'hui le c'est
vrai que ça n'attire pas forcément les
gens à venir pour le salaire parce que
quand tu vois là directeur d une
puissance aujourd'hui c'est quand même
pas un gros salaire vous mangez de la
viande alors personnellement
historiquement j'ai toujours mangé de la
viande aujourd'hui j'ai pas changer mon
fusil d'épaulé sur le fait que j'en
mange encore j'ai diminué la quantité
d'ions ça c'est très clair il ya une
charte de greenpeace qui est qui est
sorti et quelques semaines un qui était
très précise sur le sujet c'est à dire
que on est pour évidemment des élevages
digne de ce nom qui soit respectable de
respectueux des animaux on est pour la
diminution de la quantité de viande et
vous savez qu'on a une campagne sur les
cantines par exemple sur le fait de
diminuer la quantité devions donc
diminuer les quantités de viande moi je
suis quelqu'un qui de fait était
probablement dans les grandes en jouant
de veron et j'ai fortement diminué après
je fais des vraies différences entre la
viande de consommation intensive j'ai la
chance de vivre en province d'avoir des
bons colo des bons copains qu'ils soient
agriculteurs
je vois la manière dont dont on se passe
voilà des animaux chez eux la manière
dont c'est fait d'où vient d'où vient
devient la viande que je peut consommer
donc je suis pour vraiment diminué de
manière importante la quotidien elle est
beaucoup trop importante aujourd'hui et
il faut privilégier plutôt la qualité la
traçabilité de la viande éliminer sa
quantité de viande bon revenons à nos
moutons
vous avez était enfant de choeur dit
votre fiche wikipédia alors non est-ce
que c'est du pipeau non alors j'ai pas
été au fond du coeur je ne sais pas
exactement tous est sorti je pense que
c'est la personne qui avait fait son
portrait à l'époque dans le parisien qui
avait un peu à interpréter les choses
non j'ai pas était enfant de choeur mais
clairement je suis originaire d'une
famille on va dire d éducation
judéo-chrétienne et j'ai appris à parler
dans un micro dans les églises enfin je
veux dire c'est aussi simple que ça vous
votez coin je vous votez quoi ah je vois
de quoi alors ça j'ai parlé ce que je
peux vous dire déjà c'est que
personnellement je n'ai jamais adhéré à
aucun parti politique jamais aucun bas
parce que je n'ai jamais trouvé dans ma
vie pour le moment un parti politique
sur le hockey auprès duquel j'aurais
senti un engagement sincère et suffisant
j'ai été candidat mois des élections
municipales à cherbourg j'ai été élu
conseiller municipal en 1983 notre
affiche tu es le soleil non au nucléaire
et quand on me disait c'est quoi votre
programme on disait non nucléaires et
quand on lui disait mais vous avez une
satire du nom d'angleterre et à
cherbourg alors que comme je vous le
disais on est dans le mono industrie
nucléaire total à l'époque j'étais élu
avec 17 et demi pour cent des voix j'ai
des collègues jusqu'à 21% des voix donc
on a clairement
tout un tas de gens qui de fait nous
soutenaient sur notre positionnement
faut se rappeler que aux cantonales à
l'époque on avait même une femme qui
s'appelait catherine girard qui était
admirable qui a réussi à mettre en
ballottage le maire de beaumont hague
qui est ingénieur cogema l'époque et
donc quand même on voit qu'il y avait
deux représentations ça veut dire qu'ils
avaient des gens y compris qu'ils
travaillaient pour les sous-marins
nucléaires qui travaillait dans le
nucléaire le site de l'ags qui avaient
finalement voté pour les antinucléaires
bon alors qu'est ce que vous reprochez
au nucléaire
qu'est ce que je reproche lui plaire
déjà déjà une chose toute simple c'est
pour comment je suis devenu anti
nucléaires souvent la question vient
bien avant je dirais les questions
écologiques et c'est ce qui m'a le plus
choqué ma rencontre et nucléaire ça a
été les barbelés
les crs et le système que ça représente
et c'est à dire que
les premières manifs j'avais 15 ans et
je me suis retrouvé face à des cordons
de crs face à des gens qui voulaient
imposer des barbelés un endroit
magnifique à flamanville il y avait
cette falaise qui était formidable et on
nous disait non mais vous avez beau de
paille d'accord ça sera fait et ce jour
là avec peut-être ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure en éducation il y avait
un problème c'est à dire que j'ai
identifié très très vite le nucléaire
comme incompatible avec la démocratie ce
que parce qu'il y avait un projet
industriel parce que vous empêcher
d'aller là bas parce que parce que la
méthode d'imposition du nucléaire je
ressentis comme du colonialisme moi je
suis originaire de lucide de la région
de live est pour moi la guettait d'abord
un endroit une presqu'île magnifique un
endroit dans lequel on peut faire des
quantités de choses formidables et s'il
n'y avait pas eu la verrue au milieu se
serait pas ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui et
lingue si vous en parlez aux gens
ailleurs en france ou à l'étranger c'est
devenu le nom de l' usine c'est devenu
une industrie c'est devenu un problème
avec évidemment une image extrêmement
négative et j'ai pour moi on a spoilé
non on a volé le nom de cette de cet
endroit et moi j'en souffre énormément
j'ai mes racines là ma famille
maternelle est originaire de 3 km de
l'usiné de la hague et je me suis
toujours identifié cet endroit que je
trouve admirable et j'ai vu l'industrie
nucléaire comme vraiment une
colonisation de l'endroit comme des gens
qui arrivent et qui était pas chez eux
qui arrivent et qui mettait des clôtures
des barbelés des policiers et ça pour
moi c'était un ça commençait là pour
l'as s'intéresse au dossier très vite
vient la question de l'environnement par
exemple
quand on voit les villes après bien
évidemment lorsqu'on s'intéresse au
dossier très vite vient la question de
la vie la ville de l'img
j'ai une belle piscine est un beau stade
la ville et la ville est bien entretenu
il ya dédié des belles infrastructures
qui est vous je vous dis à vous peignez
de quoi en fait je dis ça souvent si
vous voulez savoir si vous allez vous
chercher une centrale nucléaire mais
avant tout en france guide et vous aux
réverbères quand on commence à avoir de
très beaux réverbère vous suivez les
réverbères la centrale avaient au bout
c'est à dire que finalement
systématiquement ces industries qui a
arrosé dans le monde rigolait sage de
pâtes ces dames en mission ils sont à
sienne les consciences on achète les
consciences il suffit de regarder ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui à bure peut-être y
revenir plus tard dans la discussion
mais bureau on veut mettre les déchets
nucléaires c'est à lui sinon c'est à
dire que c'est un endroit qui était
quand même on va dire bien on va revenir
à bien faire mais ce que je veux dire
c'est difficultés économiques blague ou
flamands vie ou les centrales
systématiquement on arrose dsk est ce
qu'il ya des protocoles d'urgence qui
sont disséminés auprès des écoles pour
prévenir s'il ya un carton si ça
commence à fuiter s'il ya des fuites
radioactives des choses comme ça ya des
protocoles qui sont saignés alors ça ça
fait le sortirait du débat permanent et
y avait une petite pastille chez vous il
ya ce qu'on appelle le ppj plan
particulier d'intervention et donc était
de 10 km autour des centrales nucléaires
qui est que 2 5 km autour logique de la
caisse qui a évidemment fort discutable
et qui vient par une déclaration de
ségolène royal à matin à 7h sur france
inter de dire on va doubler puis on
passe à 20 km la réalité c'est qu'il
suffit de regarder
les accidents dans leur réalité à
tchernobyl ou fukushima pour voir que
c'est finalement c'est certes le 20 km
ils n'ont pas grand sens parce que bien
évidemment la radioactivité va pas se
répartir selon certes mais bien au delà
et puis la question se pose même dans
ces 20 km2 quel est réellement les
mesures qui fonctionne évidemment j'ai
assisté mois de nombreux exercices à
différents endroits en france il ya
toujours la question de la veille
l'école maternelle qui est là que les
enfants confinés et ont dit à la
maîtresse mais vous allez pouvoir les
garder le combattant ai dit vous avez
les enfants dans une école comme ça au
bout de trois quarts d'heure une heure
c'est plus table et on leur dit mais
vous avez de lula vous avez toujours le
noane annoncé on a de l'eau parce qu'il
y avait exercice et finalement on
s'aperçoit qu'en france on n'est pas du
tout prêt pas du tout quand vous voyez
l'ambassade de france au japon
mettre en avant les légumes les
productions alimentaires de l'agent de
fukushima ça vous fait penser à quoi
c'est normal il faut soutenir les petits
agriculteurs le coup c'est que c'est
quoi alors il ya les deux c'est là que
c'est très très compliqué clairement il
ya des endroits aujourd'hui on oblige
les gens à revenir simplement leur
coupant les subventions qu'on leur a
donné suite aux accidents dans
l'accident on déshabille dans des
espèces de préfabriqués aujourd'hui on
leur dit ça y est la crise est passée à
il ya plus besoin de rester dans le
préfabriqué et puis nous et plus de 100
vous devez retourner chez vous et là il
retourne dans une zone qui compte un
milliard à toute une zone aussi on
retournera jamais mais il ya une partie
sur lequel on dit ben vous pouvez y
aller et et ça c'est scandaleux et puis
à côté il ya un autre problème c'est que
le préfecture tels que fukushima et
c'est très très grand ces jeux il ya eu
d'effusion évidemment des communes et on
a déposé c'est très très très grand et
comme on le disait à propos des
accidents la tâche un accident c'est pas
un cercle et si vous venez par le nord
par exemple en direction d'un central
vous pouvez vous approché à deux
kilomètres pourquoi simplement ce que le
vent était plus de 90% du temps vers
l'océan puis après il a tourné secteur
sud mais il n'a jamais passé au nord ce
qui fait que vers le bas on est dans
préfecture de fukushima et on n'a pas
été touché par l'action est là
clairement il ya des régulateurs et les
pêcheurs qui finalement ont été on s'en
sont là impacté par par l'image d'un
client et ou de fait objectivement ça
pose pas de problème de manger dans
leurs produits et à côté de ça par
contre on commence à commercialiser des
choses qui à notre avis pour une pose
problème lesquels
le le fait qu on dise que on l'a moi
j'ai vu ça sur place ça que l'on va
contrôler tous les sacs de riz on
s'aperçoit que bien que ses parents vont
dire
échantillonnage un con qu'on fait ces
contrôles et avoir la garantie
aujourd'hui que dans les zones les plus
contaminées
qui sont réouvertes cela aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de problème ça reste
évidemment extrêmement discutable bon
alors quand on prend une petite centrale
nucléaire en france
quels sont les problèmes alors les
centrales nucléaires en france donc on
se rappelle un 19 sites de centrales
nucléaires 58 58 réacteurs plus toutes
les installations qu'on dit du cycle
entre guillemets qu'on n'est pas mais
les installations de la chaîne nucléaire
c'est à dire que c'est lucy dans deux
transformations de conversion qui à 61
piscine à narbonne c'est le centre de
cadarache et le centre de marcoule de
romans sur isère et c'est souvent les
gens oublient un toutou ces structures
extrêmement grande qui quelquefois sont
de la même taille à peu près que l'usiné
de la hague dont on parle beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'autres installations donc
énormément d'installation dispatcher est
alors s'il rassure sur la question des
centrales pour nous il ya les problèmes
de ce qu'on appelle sûreté donc c'est la
question autres à sec de la centrale
elle-même c'est là la vanne qui est qui
lâche c'est le tremblement de terre qui
va affecter une tuyauterie et c'est donc
en termes de sûreté de nos centrales
faut se rappeler conçu dans les années
70 construite dans les années 80 elle
arrive à 40 ans rappelons-nous quel type
de voiture on avait dans les années 80
70 rappelons-nous la diane
rappelons-nous au salon de paris la
diane qui sort et voilà est ce que si je
dis que je mets une ceinture de sécurité
dans la diane ou que je vais je sais pas
trop quel système dessus on aura un
véhicule qui sera auprès rouler à 130
sur autoroute avec les autres évidemment
non le problème c'est que nos centrales
de fait sont arrivés à cette image
souvent que je fais un présentation je
montre ça le tableau de bord de la diane
est celui d'une voiture de jeu des
gouttes dans la diète on pourrait mais
je montre les tables peur et c'est vrai
que les centrales c'est pareil elle ne
sera non on arrive quasiment toutes à 40
ans les autres installations à peu près
au même âge et donc on a un virage elles
ont été pensés par lésés par les études
d ingénieur pour durée de trente mon
accès en aucun cas on a fait une
interview de bernard raison des rejets
pas si ça vous parle il était conseiller
un président de la république à l'époque
il nous a dit le problème
thermonucléaire on n'a pas pensé à la
déconstruction
alors on a beaucoup de choses qu'on n'a
pas pensé à l'époque on n'a pas pensé à
la déconstruction on n'a pas pensé non
plus à ce que la géostratégie l
équilibre du monde soit celui
d'aujourd'hui est donc par exemple les
actes de terrorisme pourra peut-être y
revenir plus en détail mais personne
n'ya pensé c'est à dire que nos
centrales n'ont jamais été pensé en
imaginant qu'il fallait qu'elle résiste
à un certain nombre d'agressions qui
aujourd'hui se révèle la fête et qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec les probabilités
c'est déterministe il ya des gens assez
fou pour les précipiter des avions sur
le world trade center et donc à partir
de là dit il ya des gens qui sont qui
peuvent avoir des attentions tels que
cela quand elles n'ont jamais été pensé
pour ça le fait d'en parler de le
médiatiser à try again qui sait ce que
c'est pas donner des armes à nos ennemis
alors tout d'abord on voit qu'il ya pas
besoin de nous pour que les y pense on
voit que quand vous faire les interviews
avec vous repérer les points avec les
trajets des matières quand vous un fait
une prise d'une centrale avec des feux
d'artifice pour montrer que l'on peut
aller taper une piscine ou que vous
montrer qu'on peut taper une piscine à
100 m lance-roquettes anti-char
c'est pas donner des armes aux ennemis
on est le thermomètre et la sonnette
d'alarmé et c'est pas en faisant taire
la sonnette et en faisant casser le
thermomètre qu'on va faire baisser la
fièvre c'est à dire que de toute façon
le pour la meilleure la vulnérabilité
est là alors évidemment on pourrait
éviter d'en parler nous notre but c'est
en parler parce qu'il ya des mesures à
prendre et à partir de là on continuera
systématiquement montrer où ça fait mal
rappelons-nous les années 80 ont jeté à
l'époque des déchets nucléaires en mer
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a juste été
montré les déchets et puis on a dit
regardez ça va pas du tout et dix ans
après la fête les 10 ans de campagne de
montrer des images mais aussi d'être sur
le tapis vert comme on sait faire c'est
aller dans les institutions pour obtenir
l'interdiction de jeter les déchets
nucléaires mais aujourd'hui les
personnes imaginent un plus faire ça
mais il a fallu passer par ces moments
où on met le doigt où ça fait mal pour
que la question soit posée
finalement on a quand même obtenu la
commission parlementaire qui était mise
en place avec barbara pompili donc comme
comme rapporteuse
café quand même des heures de l'audition
qui ont mis tous les problèmes sur la
table après la question serait de savoir
ce que ça va tenir est-ce que le
gouvernement va en faire quelque chose
et c est si c'est pas des gens qui vont
juste voilà à dire les choses alors
après derrière et vous pouvez compter
sur nous pour faire pour tout faire pour
que ce rapport soit suivi d'effet
simplement donc comme je disais il sait
pas encore quel est l'intérêt de dire
qu'il ya des matières radioactives qui
sont transportés dans le erreur par un
parisien l'intérêt déjà c'est de montrer
que personne n'est à l'abri de la
question parce que les gens pourraient
se dire après touché du doigt la
centrale nucléaire même si personne
n'est très loin des centrales nucléaires
en france mais qu'elle les gens pour
avoir le sentiment finalement qui ne
sont pas concernés or ces cuves de
nitrates duras nil qui part de la hague
pour aller à pierrelatte de fait on les
a vus sur le réseau rer c'est une
réalité bon
de fait les camions de plutonium a une
chance sur quatre il ya quelques
parcours c'est la francilienne donc qui
passe à vélizy sur la francilienne et
c'est bon dans ses camions
250,56 avec 1 300 quand y en a deux et
parce que toute l'espagne à deux pas
cela nagasaki ses huit kilos de
plutonium 8 kg là il reste 150 par
camion tous les lundi matins et donc
nous on se fait un devoir de dire est un
problème qui est là et il doit être
traité si si de fait par exemple secret
fonctionner mais alors nous devons pas
aller voir non plus le fait est que
malgré tout ce qui est dit par l'état
aujourd'hui la sécurité des peintures et
la radio qui dix exclusions coin alors
la radioactivité se mesure en becquerel
parce que ça c'est ce qui fait que l'on
peut mesurer le nombre de déflagrations
ça alors ça c'est long on aime bien
parler nyon becquerels parce que au
moins c'est ce qui va se mesurer comme
je peux mesurer en litres un réservoir
d'essence ou alors la demi vie du
plutonium c'est quoi alors ça l'est pour
lequel la demi vie par exemple du
plutonium 239 ses 24 millions
et on considère donc qu'il sera inerte
enfin plus dangereux pour pour redire
l'humanité au bout de dix période pour
que 240 points et maillot donc le jeu
mais je voulais juste finir sur le
l'histoire d'une des unités donc le
becquerel cc c'est donc le donc l'unité
qui va pouvoir mesurer la source de
radioactivité ça c'est indiscutable
alors après là où il ya plus de
difficultés c'est quand on parle de six
verres soumis ni ses moeurs qui est
l'impact de ces becquerels survient sur
/ en gros c'est vrai vous si vous êtes
avec un pommier le nombre de pommes qui
vont tomber ça c'est les becquerels et
puis après on va regarder l'afrique la
quantité de bétail que vous et recevoir
avec engrais puis après il ya l'impact
sur vous c'est le nombre de points que
vous est pris ce que ça vous avoir fait
comme des là or là on rentre dans un
débat politique
puisque derrière il ya des facteurs cas
qui sont des factures d'impact décrétée
par des scientifiques qui continue
d'avoir un débat permanent et
aujourd'hui ce débat jamais tranché et
on n'est pas égaux face à ces décrets
vous moi c'est chez vous comprenez bien
que par exemple quelqu'un qui va fumer
va voir à pouvoir de roger inférieur à
quelqu'un qui lui va et sportifs plus
plus facilement recracher ski pour
absorber etc on voit bien qu'un enfant
par exemple va être beaucoup plus
fragile par rapport parlons pas du
strontium 90 qui est un événement proche
du calcium a dérivé du calcium s'il en
pleine calcification il va tout garder
et là il va se contaminer et garder se
consomme 90 puis on va avoir une
personne qui est beaucoup plus âgées et
plus tôt aurait calcification finalement
strontium 90 s en fiche un peu chaque
radio éléments et a donc une valeur est
un élément chimique qui va se fixer plus
ou moins sur les différentes parties et
partie du club
quand on voit à fukushima
mesures de radioactivité qui ne sont pas
à hauteur d'enfant c'est normal c'est
pas normal c'est une standardisation de
la mesure c'est quoi
le problème de de fukushima c'est que
comme on le disait c'est que c'est
plutôt ce qu'on appelle les taches de
léopard c'est assez différent voilà la
contamination et comme je vous le disais
on peut être assez près par le nord par
exemple et on peut avoir des tâches très
contaminée vraiment à plusieurs dizaines
de kilomètres souvent dans des points de
concentration qui peuvent être parce
qu'il ya des toitures qui vont avoir
concentré de la radioactivité avec la
pluie les choses comme ça donc c'est
compliqué le problème après c'est la
question de savoir ce qu'on peut
nettoyer ou des contaminés et à
fukushima on a tendance à dire bah
écoutez là c'est bon pour moi parce qu
on a nettoyé la route qui ont nettoyé
les maisons
sauf que à l'arrière des maisons il y
assez petit piqué avec des planches et
qu'ils lisent au-delà de ça faut pas y
aller il faut pas y aller pourquoi parce
que là on ne peut pas d'écho terminé
avec un problème souvent aussi c'est
qu'on a commencé à décontaminer par le
bas et que évidemment avec le
ruissellement tout a tendance à à
redescendre alors après la polémique sur
les mesures assez de ces stations de
mesure elle est importante parce
qu'elles ont été mises dans des endroits
discutable et souvent des séries toyer
au tour donc aujourd'hui la
radioactivité c'est pas dans l'air la
radioactivité c'est le sol le problème
c'est ce qui va donc irradier les gens
par le sol et puis la consommation des
produits donc c'est bien là que la dose
peut peut intervenir qu'en tepco dit que
la l'eau contaminée ou tout fukushima
de sa centrale va être lâchés en mer ça
représente harris est ce que la dilution
sera suffisamment importante est-ce que
c'est pas une solution comme une autre
alors cette question de
ce qu'il ya dans les cuves elle est
fondamentale c'est la question qu'il y a
beaucoup de tricia sommes dans cette eau
principalement gars aussi d'autres un
peu d'eau tradionnellement qui peuvent
traîner mais essentiellement du tritium
à la évidemment là aussi on est face à
un débat on va dire éthique à débat
moral de savoir ce qu'on accepte c'est à
dire que les doses ne sont pas des doses
qui sont calculées en fonction d'un
risque zéro mais de une acceptation d'un
certain nombre de conséquences et là la
question qui a été posée moi j'ai été
quand le directeur de la centrale nous
dit m'écouter pourquoi vous voulez pas
que je rejette le tritium alors que ce
que j'ai dans mes cuves c'est seulement
vous avez al alagui vous en rejeté deux
fois et demie ce que j'ai dans mes cuves
et c'est vrai c'est à dire que
l'autorisation d'agde aujourd'hui en
rangée est tellement énorme aujourd'hui
que finalement évidemment lui il
s'appuie là-dessus pour dire mais ce que
vous avez ce qu'on a nous aussi avons
reçu main sert à rien de regarder c'est
pas un problème alors le problème c'est
que c'est pas parce que c'est pas un
problème à fukushima c'est que c'est un
énorme problème à la hague c'est là le
problème qui skiait dans ces discussions
le problème c'est que le tritium c'est
un dérivé de l'hydrogène 1 ch 3
donc on considère qu' il va assez
facilement se diluer dans la masse de
l'océan alors après faut regarder aussi
les choses telles qu'elles sont la x1
roger qui se fait quand même dans le raz
blanchard dans un puits d'appoint
courants extrêmement puissant
bras fukushima là où il veut le faire le
rejet c'est totalement différent mais le
long d'une côte sur lequel il ya des
zones où ça peut sédimenter ce fait il
peut y avoir des du fait que ça reste
dans la zone donc c'est très différent
puis une question morale comment ces
gens coupables d'un accident et qui ont
donc contaminés et en pose un problème
économique gigantesque à ses pêcheurs
peuvent opposer aujourd'hui lors dire
alarme attendait alors oui c'est vrai la
sape a bien marché en plus oui ce qu'il
ya dans les cuves tout le monde sait que
c'est gras duty fait que ces quotas mis
ne dit rien non plus ça on va vous le
remettre aussi dans la mer est un vrai
problème moral voix pour le meetic
vous avez parlé d'un de fukushima de
décontamination du stockage des déchets
est ce qu'on peut parler de la
sous-traitance dans le milieu du
nucléaire par exemple à fukushima il ya
eu une polémique de travail mafieux de
gens des clodos comme ils appellent ça
qui ont travaillé là bas ça on est où là
la sous traitance dans l'intérieur au
japon et en france ouais c'est un
problème global je dirais que
systématiquement faut bien penser que
les sous traitants c'est eux qui
prennent les douze jr faut faire c'est à
dire que c'est eux qui vont faire les
arrêts de tranche
quand on arrête une stratégie claire
pour faire la maintenance quand il a
besoin d'intervenir auprès des
générateurs de vapeur qui sont eux très
radioactifs c'est les sous traitants qui
y vont être très radioactifs très
radioactifs c'est le fait qu'il va
falloir se protéger pas resté longtemps
parce qu'on va cumuler de la 12,1 à
briller les nuits n'ont pas brillé la
nuit je dire ça ça reste dans les
fantasmes voilà au pas brillé la nuit on
va on va on peut avoir une irradiation
qui va amener à des vieillissement des
cellules qui peut exposer des problèmes
de santé qui peut affaiblir le système
immunitaire etc et puis on peut avoir
des contaminations à absorber la qui
peut poser des problèmes de santé aussi
non la sous traitance est un vrai gros
problème c'est à dire qu'il ya des
habitudes qui ont été faites de par edf
de sous-traiter je crois qu'on est à peu
près 80% des tâches d'entretien des
lacets du parc nucléaire qui aujourd'hui
fait pas par la sous traitance alors au
début c'étaient des tâches on voyait un
peu particulière qui était dédiée
maintenant on trouve aussi charneau cheo
renault par exemple des pans entiers des
unités qui ont été sous traitée donc
avec l'épreuve de compétences à la
transmission de la compétence etc et ça
c'est un vrai problème à fukushima on a
eu cette histoire évidemment dia cousin
qui avait proposé à des gens un peu
partout dans le japon et qui étaient
souvent des gens en situation de
détresse bah écoutez on va vous payer
fort bien on vous emmène en bus et vous
allez faire un travail sur la centrale
là où des gens qui eux étaient
conscients du danger n'aurait pas été
ils ont vu évidemment de la manoeuvre de
la manoeuvre a pas cher et facilement
manipulable
mais je dirais que c'est un peu après
1.2 général rappelons nous que sur le
chantier le père de flamanville en
france bouygues a été condamné pour donc
des emplois qui étaient des employés
l'îlot donc à travers d'une société il
avait employé de manière illégale
plusieurs centaines de personnes sur le
chantier de le père donc ce phénomène de
la sous traitance c'est vraiment moins
une manière de déléguer les risques à
des travailleurs et puis c'est aussi
faire des économies aujourd'hui sur un
nucléaire qui est en train d'exploser au
niveau des prix revenons sur votre
petite sauterie que vous avez organisé
dans une centrale
vous étiez à la manette vous avez fait
péter
un feu d'artifice pour montrer qu'on
pouvait approcher très rapidement d'une
piscine de stockage c'est quoi le risque
d'une piscine de stockage alors le
respect des piscines c'est quelque chose
qui est assez peu connu les gens ils ont
découvert ça que vous coucher mais
finalement c'est beau placer dome de
gens depuis longtemps ça y est d'attirer
l'attention il ya des spécialistes
américains comme bomb bomb alvarez qui
est un grand spécialiste question qui
tue mais attendez on a un gros problème
c'est autant les piscines que les
réacteurs mais ça a un peu de gens l'ont
écouté et puis cette question de la
piscine cas de fukushima dans lequel il
fait lui remettre de l'eau parce que
sinon on pouvait avoir un feu nucléaire
les gens ont compris que là on pouvait
avoir un problème de ce côté là alors
ces piscines le problème c'est que comme
je vous le disais ils ont été pensés au
moment des centrales nucléaires avant
qu'on imagine des possibilités d'une
agression extérieure de malveillance
donc finalement elles sont construites
avec du béton classique comme on aurait
construit n'importe quelle installation
sans protection particulière et ses
piscines elles peuvent contenir jusqu'à
trois fois le volume en radioactivité du
coeur lui même c'est que suivant les
phases de travail on a le volume d'à
coeur à peu près qui en désactivation à
refroidissement avant d'être transportés
vers la hague on a des combustibles qui
sont en attente soit déchargée soit qui
sont stockés là plus le volume du coeur
qui a été pris qui a été mis à côté le
temps qu'on travaille dans le réacteur
ce qui fait que par moments on a ce
qu'on appelle à terme source une
quantité de radioactivité qui peut être
jusqu'à trois fois ce qui est novateur
et là on n'a pas d'enceinte de
confinement on n'a aucune protection ce
qui fait que s'il y avait un trou dans
la piscine on aurait appel à des noyages
à une perte de l'eau et à ce moment là
évidemment les combustibles arriverait à
hors de l'eau là on aurait donc
évidemment échauffement on aurait un feu
ddd des combustibles fonte des
combustibles
hélas elles sont la pire c'est
d'ailleurs même si on est à la moitié de
l'eau parce que là on va s'y tenir en
plus où l'ol va se décomposer avec donc
le phénomène avec le comment un jeune
homme qui va donc fabriqué entre
guillemets de l'hydrogène celle que ça
va brûler si j'ai un terroir d'hydrogène
c'était drôle gêne au dessus de 4% ses
explosifs et là évidemment de ne pas
cher de la structure de des piscines qui
ne sont pas fait du tout pour rester ce
qui fait que en termes de conséquences
avec une les piscines d'entreposage
on pourrait avoir des conséquences
finalement nettement supérieur à ce
qu'on aurait que le réacteur lui même on
pourrait avoir quelque chose qui serait
nettement supérieur à ce qu'on a connu
il ya enfin fukushima ou tchernobyl
watchers nommé donc là si ça pète de
l'hydrogène pour résumer trivialement
donc ça des gueules partout il ya des
morceaux qui veulent par tous des
morceaux très radioactifs 6 à fond il ya
aucune
structure pour récupérer la galette de
corium rien rien rien au genre c'est la
piscine municipale avec des bâtons c'est
pour ça que cet accident aujourd'hui est
considéré comme impossible mais vous
êtes un grand malade de montrer sa
nathalie la réalité cela ce que je
disais c'est vous pouvez toujours dire
je veux pas voir on peut tous dans le
déni la réalité c'est que c'est la
situation de piscines en france hors
d'europe et que et aux états unis et que
donc à partir de là on peut toujours
faire mine de ne pas savoir la réalité
c'est que demain ça peut se produire
lorsque la seule chose qui est prévu
aujourd'hui c'est en termes de sûreté
c'est à dire que ce qui est prévu par
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire c'est de
dire si j'ai rupture de tubulures par
cisaille vente parce qu'il ya un séisme
par exemple donc j'ai une certain
mi-août fuite je peux avoir un
siphonnage par les systèmes de
refroidissement de la piscine donc on va
calculer avec ce tout de suite et
aujourd'hui on demande quoi edf en
demande un élève de pouvoir compenser la
perte d'eau alors il ya ce qu'on appelle
des bâches en huppertz et des cuves en
fait acquis sur dessus des fois
d'ailleurs posé sur le fameux toi ok pas
protégés et donc on assez qu avec l'eau
qui est censé revenir dans la piscine
évidence avec chute d'un mur en plus y'a
plus de l'autre du match mais bon
admettons cépages donc doivent remplir
la piscine mais là on est bien dans un
cadre d'accidents de sûreté donc une
petite fuite mais si vous avez un trou
de trois mètres carrés au milieu de la
piscine pour le mieux régler un aucun
homme ne pourra plus approcher certains
radioactivité est telle qu'aucune
intervention technique des possibles et
en solutions passives pour empêcher
un
ennemi potentiel
est fracturé la paroisse de la piscine
aqualia des gendarmes et des batteries
un solaire il ya des chiens il ya des
oies alors ça c'est jamais un
surveillant les lectrices assez la
protection active la protection active
ces actifs la protection passive c'est
l'épaisseur des murs c'est de la
protection qui fait que en dehors de
toute intervention humaine justement pas
l'installation elle même si un avion
tombe s'il était quelqu'un tire avec une
requête qui se passera rien ou peu de
choses ça c'est la protection passive
les gens là c'est votre allegri qui
s'intéressent à ces la protection active
vous avez bien baisés quand même et
c'est ce qu'on a fait depuis des années
c'était montrer
le fait que ça fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui tels que c'est parce qu'il
faut se rappeler comme que les psp gère
2007 et sont mis en place à cause de vos
images on a vu les images vous êtes
rentrer là dedans comme dans du beurre
oui oui on rentre facilement dans
l'avenir de demain matin on peut y
retourner non non non non non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est c'est
extrêmement facile et ça c'est un gros
problème alors depuis à centre d'études
qui sera en cours comme je le disais les
pelotons spéciaux comptes est mis en
place pour les centrales de choucroute
ou secondes pendant pendant cette petite
sauterie organisée là bas vous étiez
habillés en jaune avait des panneaux and
peace donc les uns les gendarmes ils
vous ont mis en joue ils ont fait
quelque chose
dis donc déjà la règle générale
systématiquement ce que qu'ils arrivent
trop tard c'est à dire qu'au moment
pourrait être en mesure de
contrebalancer une action intérieure ça
serait trop tard ça serait fini hier le
mec avait quand même eu le temps s'il
avait voulu dégainer il aurait pu vous
êtes car il pouvait dégager mais le truc
tu allumes et donc le feu il partait
quand même donc il était trop tard donc
et puis alors vous savez il ya cette
réponse toujours qui a été dire oui mais
nos gendarmes auront une attitude
différente si c'est chez terrorisme ce
qui est totalement exact sauf que si ce
n'est des terroristes ils auraient aussi
l'attitude totalement différente de ce
que nous on a et je donne pas cher des
deux gendarmes face au oui collègues qui
étaient à l'intérieur c'est l'image et
le terroriste où je donne pas cher à la
classe des quatre gendarmes face à 22 mi
temps qu'ils étaient entrés dans la
centrale c'est ces gens là avaient été
armés bien sûr ils sont combien les
gendarmes alors les gendarmes quand vous
entendez le chiffre de dave ça fait
super bien et est plus de 1000 gendarmes
c'est vrai sauf que si vous considérez
qu'il font le dompter 5,8 plus je
voudrais ajouter le pourcentage habituel
de malades ou de gens en congé vous
apercevez que dans la réalité ils sont
cinq ou six par son train pas plus et ça
c'est ça c'est ce qui serait optimal est
en réalité quand on y va nous on
s'aperçoit que au mieux ils étaient
quatre classes ils étaient deux à
inquiéter non ça c'est pas nous puis je
fus dont on rapporte gendarmerie ça
c'est vu puisqu'il ya eu justice et
tribunal il suffit de la regarder c'est
parfaitement clair et en général il ya
cinq six gardiens privés on va dire de
qui sont là de gardiennage qui sont là
mais qui n'interviennent pas donc on est
vraiment extrêmement faible d'ailleurs
la députée perrine goulet qui voulait
absolument nous tirer dessus si jamais
entrer dans les centres avec a fini par
dire non mais je voulais pas dire qu'il
fallait les tuer mais tiré dans les
jambes ce qui était quand même assez
comique elle a réclamé dans le cadre de
la commission que il faut qu'ils aient
au moins donc huit personnes du pspg par
réacteur alors là à voir parce que
évidemment le coût pour edf va être
autre chose non la réalité c'est qu'il
ya plein de mesures a étudié centrale
par centrale si on prend l'exemple de la
centrale de borssele en hollande ils ont
fait un tumulus tout autour un matin de
janvier à une butte de terre évidemment
ça ferme pas ne s'empêche pas tous hein
ça empêchera pas un avion que ces drames
et sa ferme déjà le tir direct à chaque
fois qu'on peut fermer une porte il faut
fermer la porte en termes de sécurité
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout le cas en
france il ya des systèmes etc sont
extrêmement disparates selon les
centrales et en a qui sont un peu mieux
protéger d'autres termes un conte et
caméras il ya d'autres camps n'ont pas
fait c'est à vous avez chiffré tout ça
parce que c'est ce que ça coûterait à
l'état français de sécurité de ses
centrales toutes ces piscines reste
extrêmement cher c'est quoi extrêmement
chat
si vous voulez nous la seule le chef
chiffres on peut vous donner c'est qu'on
a regardé le prix ce qu'il faudrait pour
bunkeriser les piscines et là on avait
sorti une première étude sur lequel on
annonce et 500 millions à peu près entre
la piscine par pitié donc fausses à son
encontre et à 1063 piscine oui et là
dessus jacques repussard avec ce
directeur de l'irsn qui vient de partir
en retraite il nous disait à nous
écouter vous chief n'est pas déconner
c'est le mot qui utilisait à l'époque de
plus on affine et en faisant travailler
des gens des ingénieurs qui travaillent
vraiment ce génie civil etc ils sont
arrivés eux entre 750 et 1 milliard 2
c'est ce qu'il faudrait pour arriver à
vraiment beau gars iseppi on parle gros
chiffres vous connaissez peut-être pas
ce que je demandais combien ça coûte de
démonter une centrale alors j'ai pas de
chiffres simplement parce que
aujourd'hui personne ne sait c'est à
dire que pourquoi c'est vous fait marrer
ah parce que c'est un débat parce que
c'est un débat permanent dans lequel edf
vous dira ça coûte pas cher on va y
arriver c'est facile et puis il ya
d'autres endroits dans lequel ce qui est
sûr c'est que la france est celle qui
provisionne le moins pour le
démantèlement de ses centrales
nucléaires on a des facteurs de 1 à 7
suivant le suivant les pays les seuls
exemples on va dire de démantèlement
achevé c'est aux états unis il ya
quelques centrales qui sont appel retour
à l'herbe à c'est à dire qu'il ya plus
de des clôtures du combustible stocké
dans des bunkers et puis rien d'autre
mais qu'ils étaient des centrales qui
étaient détenus en moins puissantes et
détenant plus donc
vous dire accessible et plus facile à
démanteler et souvent il y avait un seul
réacteur nous la difficulté évidemment
des réacteurs qui sont les uns à côté
des autres sur une même sur un même site
donc clairement ce qui est sûr c'est que
là c'est pas nous qui le disons la cour
des comptes l'a dit et répété il ya une
sous-évaluation des coûts aujourd'hui en
france la seule chose qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'on ayant comparé avec les
autres pays voilà on est à trois fois
moins que l'allemagne par exemple donc
voilà et le problème c'est que l'argent
il n'est souvent pas disponible il a été
réinvesti 5 à partir du moment où on a
de l'argent qui est pas disponible si un
jour malheureusement df continue sur le
chemin où elle est de plonger ben c'est
vous et moi qui finiront par sortir des
billets pour payer tout ça ou pas
on en fait quoi des déchets par les
déchets les déchets
vaste sujet il va y avoir un débat qui
va débuter sur les déchets nucléaires en
décembre
sur un truc c'est à l'acronyme un peu
compliqué mais pngmdr c'est le plan
national de gestion des déchets et
matières radioactives est donc ce plan
national quelque chose qui est
obligatoire légalement il est remis à
jour tous les trois ans est là il va
faire l'objet d'un débat national animé
par une commission particulière du débat
public avec des débats en région et ses
débats dont les organisations locales
autour de bus ont déjà dit qu'elles
boycotteraient ces débats parce qu'elles
considèrent que
parce qu'on les prend pour des imbéciles
que finalement on va les faire débattre
de la couleur des cheminées et pas du
reste ce qui est un vrai sujet la
question de céder barracuda qu il serve
as que qui est ce que quelque chose va
changer à l'arrivée et donc les déchets
on a en france évidemment pas le pays
qui a le plus de déchets parce
qu'évidemment en proportion du nombre
d'habitants et de nombreux directeurs on
a une quantité phénoménale de déchets
c'est quoi cette quantité alors alors
les quantités tout dépend de ce qu'on
appelle un déchet là on est en finale
ment désaccord total avec l'industrie du
clair puisque l'industrie nucléaire a
réussi à force de deux bagarres
légistatives en particulier soutenu par
des députés régulièrement à faire
changer progressivement la loi c'est à
dire que il ya eu la loi de 91 des coups
à bata qui était finie c'est à peu près
ce qui était à déchets puis après il ya
eu la loi de 2006 et en 2006 on a dit
n'est pas un déchet nucléaire toutes les
matières dont un usage est prévu ou
envisagées alors là c'est encore mieux
envisager
ça a été une ressource je peux dire ce
qu'on veut ça devient des réserves
énergétiques pour les générations
futures et d'envoyer c'est formidable
d'avoir des milliers de tonnes de ces
produits qui sont stockés qui sont
jamais utilisées parce que bien
évidemment il n'y a pas de réutilisation
prévu mais comme on a montré qu' elle
faisabilité technique c'est vrai qu'elle
faisabilités techniques d'écouté on peut
le faire donc voir le franc indirect
alors laissez exemple les combustibles
sorte de des centrales nucléaires arrive
à l'ags 1200 tonnes de combustible
irradié par an qui arrive à l'ags sur
ses 1200 tonnes dans les piscines ont
retraite 1050 il reste 150 celle-là et
cumulent le plus en plus dans les
piscines ce qu'ils font que c'est
maintenant au bord de la saturation
parce qu'il ya 150 tonnes en particulier
de mots qui sont stockés ont fait rien
le res qui est une combinaison uranium
plutôt uranium plutonium et le reste on
le retraite était alors à nous on va
utiliser le mot recyclage bon élan dans
les faits on va avoir 1 à 2% c'est du
plutonium et ça c'est vrai qu'à une
partie qui est réutilisé dans le box
dont on parle et que tu t'en dans quelle
partie de l'acquis paradoxe 1 dans
l'usiné à marcoule dans lequel on va
réutiliser une partie à côté on a 3 4%
ce qu'on appelle les buts déchets
vitrifiés qu on a vitrifié qu'on a mis
dans du verre ceux qui rêvent de mettre
un jour on trouve à bure et ça s'était
très haute activité et qui contient les
productions les transuraniens et qu'on
va mettre dans du verre et puis à côté
on à 96% à peu près qu'élu rt uranium de
retraitement dont on nous dit que on
pourrait les utiliser
la réalité c'est que tout ça ça retourne
à pierrelatte s'est mis sous une forme
stable ou 3,8 à celle d'uranium est ok
dans des fûts actuellement il ya plus de
30 mille tonnes plus de 30 mille tonnes
c'est vraiment astronomique un de ces
déchets qui sont stockés à pierrelatte
alors évidemment nous les appels déchets
parce que l'on sait très bien que ça
sera pas réellement utilisé du côté de
renault on vous dit recyclable
d'ailleurs il ya quelques années il y
avait même des panneaux qui disait 96 %
recyclé vont les attaquer là dessus
maintenant sont plus prudents ils
mettent recyclables réalité c'est que
c'est pas recyclés donc en fait on à ces
milliers de tonnes de déchets qui sont
là et puis les opérations de
retraitement génère des déchets
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire que les
solvants qui vont utiliser les outils
etc etc start tout cela va créer des
déchets supplémentaires les solvants
terre qu'on dépasse tous et l'acide
le principe général c'est d'abord on
couple ça en branle les assemblages
quatre médecins dont à peu près on
couple ça en petits morceaux de 2 cm 1
ou 5 5 cm ça tourne dans un panier dans
le panier ça descend dans l'acide
nitrique chaud ça dissous et après par
des procédés physiques ou chimiques dont
pas peut-être pas entrer dans tous les
détails mais on va séparer les trois
éléments principaux par purification var
du plutonium d'un côté un qui est ce une
forme d'oxydé payer ou deux on va avoir
les déchets donc on va envoyer vers la
vitrification et puis envoie un
l'uranium de retraitement qui est sous
une forme liquide mélangez avec cet
acide nitrique qui elle va repartir à
pierrelatte là on va retirer l'acide
pour stocker l'uranium d'entre nous on
fait quoi de l'acide alors là s'il ya
une partie qui est recyclé qui remonte
quand même une partie seulement parce
que bien évidemment une assise de
contact avec une base et perd évidemment
de son efficacité donc faut remettre de
la c29 régulièrement à une question
internet qui dit à par greenpeace qui
est-ce qui a attaqué les centrales
qui rentrait dans les centrales attaque
et descend à traquer on n'a pas vraiment
attaqué ma vue 2d des drones survolaient
toutes les instances oui oui à ça si ces
références à cette question des drones
c'est un vrai problème c'est à dire
qu'en 2014
on découvre que
sur un des sites internet d'edf sur une
centrale c'est encore une de tes idées
yannick ça non non non non pas seulement
pas regarder ça peut regarder dans les
yeux absolument pas nous donc on
découvre à queue il ya un survol à
cattenom et puis on survole sans
personne qui en a un autre à graville et
puis on fait la synthèse et finalement
il y avait eu déjà une très grande série
de survol dont certains à saclay aussi
en région parisienne et le problème
c'est que c'était pas nous donc là
immédiatement il a décidé de communiquer
je peux vous assurer que l'après midi
même j'ai envoyé un mail à l'asn ou
achèvent tsa ou fonctionnaire défense et
de sécurité et à lire et seine pour leur
dire attention fait cette gaffe c'est
pas nous parce qu'évidemment la facilité
c'est de penser que c'est greenpeace est
pas chercher les responsables et là on
pouvait avoir un gros problème donc on
l'a dit et on le répète ce n'était pas
nous c'est les vols de jour devenir ce
que quand nous on fait un survol c'est
arrivé un on l'a fait un live en 2011 on
l'a fait objet on le dit nous on a
toujours revendiqué ce qu'on fait on est
ouvert et on dit publiquement ce qu'on
fait on n'a jamais caché quelque chose
qu'on faisait et puis on en serait
incapable de faire voler autant de
drones en même temps enfin je veux dire
que nous enfin à deux d'accord mais
qu'on fasse l'exemple du 14 novembre qui
s'est produit en 2014 où on a en même
temps toute cette série de survol
évidemment il ya un problème là c'est à
dire qu'il ya des gens qui sont en
capacité de se coordonner de faire à la
même heure des survols des survols aussi
dans certains cas qui ont nécessité des
engins autre chose que ce qu'on achète
chez le marchand de maquette d'un côté
du géant du genre est capable de
survoler à deux rondes
flamanville
poursuivi par des hélicoptères deux
hélicoptères gazelle de l'armée capable
d'en avoir un qui traverse toute la baie
de siouville vos villes pour arriver au
dessus du site de la hague repartir avec
les deux perdent quelle distance
bonne vingtaine de kilomètres quoi et
les hélicoptères les perdent donc ça
veut dire qu'on a des machines qui ont
une bonne autonomie des machines qui ont
des capacités importantes puisque
souvent plus saison des éclairages qui
cherche pas une discrète au contraire
qui veulent se montrer l'exemple de
pierrelatte où il ya un projet qui
éclaire le le sol bien évidemment si on
veut faire quelque chose de discret type
e âge on se montre pas comme ça des
conditions atmosphériques pas créé
smallville qui était ce jour-là vendre
70 km/heure et il pleuvait et elle
survole quand même ça vous fait passer
avec un drone classique il faut un truc
qui déjà bien performant
voilà après il ya les témoignages des
gens de différents sites qui nous on
nous parlait la plupart du temps ils
témoignent que c'était des ailes delta
forme d'aile delta avec donc des
lumières dessus ça vous est pas venu
l'idée par exemple que ce soit un
service de renseignement alors les verts
la première idée qui
me qui ferait une
menace fictifs alors nos centrales pour
vous exciter un petit peu pour nous
rajouter un coup sûr nous centre choses
comme ça non nous on a pensé à un
service parallèle français qui teste la
sécurité intérieure et qui aurait eu
comme idée de devoir de faire des choses
pour attirer l'attention sur le fait que
c'est il faudrait des budgets etc pour
protéger que nous là pour ça sauf que
quand j'ai entendu mise intérieur
bernard cazeneuve dire gdg ordonné d
abattre et c'est que la plaisanterie à
continuer là
cette éventualité on l'a évacué parce
que je pense qu'à un moment donné quand
même il n'aurait pas joué avec l'image
d'edf à ce moyen et c'est donc là on est
arrivé à la conclusion que c'était pas
ça
et objectivement aujourd'hui on n'a pas
de la poignée après il ya eu des
quantités de pressions faites sur des
états par moments par d'autres états
mais nous le dimensionnement l
organisation nous a fait penser beaucoup
plus à quelque chose d'une organisation
d'un type étatiques que deux plaisantins
qui s'amuse
donc le risque d'un petit drone quant à
l'or il m'aide à un petit drone en tant
qu elle si c'est un petit drogue était
très faible parce que le drone lui-même
peu n'avait pas c'était le cas en tout
cas ce que l'on a eu des témoignages
n'est pas forcément d emport extrêmement
performant maintenant aujourd'hui tout
le monde sait qu'il ya des drones
capables d'emmener plusieurs dizaines de
kilos plusieurs dizaines ces utilisés
dans l'agriculture pour la dispersion de
produits phytosanitaires c'est utilisé
dans le dans le cinéma avec des roses
caméra maintenant donc voilà des drones
capables d'emmener 40 kg et si vous avez
40 kilos de tnt évidemment sans la
piscine d'une centrale ça pose un gros
problème après ça peut être aussi
l'organisation de plusieurs drones on a
vu que puy du fou on a fait des balais
avec des drones qui sont qui se dirigent
les uns par rapport aux autres donc on
peut imaginer ces drones organisé donc
si un époque capable de faire le trou où
on va mais plusieurs fait un trou donc
je pense que l'un scénario de science
fiction ça je crois qu'aujourd'hui là le
problème qu'on a c'est que la
technologie évolue beaucoup plus vite
calé mesure de les contrôler sur sa
canne y prit le prix de la caméra
thermique qui est passée de 1000
centaines de milliers d'euros ou 1,40
euro c'est tout ça c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il suffit de commander en
chine tous les éléments qui vont bien
par internet pour fabriquer de son drone
et faire des drones extrêmement
performant
alors je mets à peu près toutes sortes
de choses peuvent être faites de cette
manière là donc très poule d face à sa
basse et le déni comme d'habitude un
parti à partir d'un moment il n'y a pas
de réponse c'est toujours bas c'est pas
un problème parce que vient aussi si on
admet que son état mais quand on n'a pas
de réponse mal malgré tout il a été
admis que c'en était un puisqu'il ya eu
cette commission parlementaire à
l'épaule qu'avec le ps quelques faits
des auditions dans lequel était décidé
de lancer ce programme de recherche de
contre mesures pour protéger les
centrales il ya eu ce sommet à
eurosatory sur donc qui s'est fait avec
comment la présentation de contrôle jure
alors ces drones qui jette un filet sur
les autres axes étaient enfin toutes ces
jeux c'est contre mesures qui finalement
sont
inefficaces
la seule mesure vraiment efficace et les
systèmes laser chinois qui est qui
marche sur un périmètre très limité et
où il faudra en mettre tellement autour
des centrales qu'on arrive à vous là
aussi et des sommes astronomiques alors
je dis pas qu'ils n'arriveront pas à
trouver les contre mesures pour le
moment tout cas tirer dessus bon avec
une belle bon bah comment comment
commencer un niveau de richesse
l'affiché aura coûté je pense que comme
beaucoup fichier s on doit y est dans
l'organisation je rappelle quand même
que la fiche est ce parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui kiffent hontas
aussi là dessus c'est avant tout on dire
une fiche de suivi c'est à dire que
probablement quand même que des
gendarmes qui me voir à côté d'une
installation nucléaire ben alors ski et
pianote il pourra voir évidemment le
réflexe de prévenir à au lieu que
monsieur roux t il à côté des centrales
nucléaires et que voilà il est là après
je pense qu'en faire chier quoi mais
voilà donc très probablement que
que ce suivi les actifs après on a
toujours eu ça rappelons nous
le hacking de l'ordinateur de yannick
jadot part par une boîte de on va dire
une petite boîte qui avait été payé par
edf pour faire le hacking voilà donc on
sait que ça fait partie du jeu entre
guillemets
vous avez été interpellé par la police
vous avez été interrogé par as des
séries au quatrième sous-sol selon la
nouvelle loi perez et samaël café vous
même pas si j'ai bu un café sur place ce
possible non ça durait ça a duré sept
heures c'était un interrogatoire en
règle sur / en fait
la principale question c'est comment
j'ai peut avoir accès à des quantités
d'informations qui normalement sont
classifiés
c'est ça le problème en fait à travers
l' enquête qui a eu lieu c'était pas
forcément été visés leur problème c'est
de comprendre comment il ya des gens qui
peuvent nous donner des informations
est-ce qu'ils comprennent pas c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses où il n'y a
pas besoin d'informations
les camions de plutonium je leur ai
expliqué il suffit de prendre le rapport
annuel de l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
qui explique et qui met même des photos
qu'il ya du transport de plutonium alors
après il n'ya pas le détail mais par
exemple dit oui mais vous avez dit
qu'ils allaient 150 kg c'est vrai que
c'est pas écrire dans 50 kg semic dix
conteneurs de 15 kg chacun bon et tout
est comme ça donc il suffit qu'on
s'intéresse à la question pour avoir les
éléments tout est disponible après les
parcours les horaires il suffit de se
mettre à côté du site de la hague et les
regarder passer et puis après il suffit
d'un peu suivre et c est donc finalement
quel est l'intérêt de dire que les
chauffeurs font toujours le plein la
même station mais s'est montré leur
faiblesse parce que pourquoi ces camions
on s'est quand même aujourd'hui mon avis
faire un semi remorque est capable
d'avoir une autonomie de 1200 km or ces
camions aujourd'hui qui transporte le
plutonium sont obligés de s'arrêter sur
total et pourquoi j'étais dalle parce
que j'ai un carte d'abonnement d'une
viendriez pu penser que la devise
bon ils ont fait des progrès parce que
depuis qu'on a dénoncé des choses il
s'arrête pas de long de la route pour
aller tous pc dans le champ laissant la
porte ouverte donc il ya des choses
qu'on ait du progrès les choses que
voilà ils s'arrêtent pas pour mettre des
pièces au péage de l'autoroute comme le
faisait avant quand même il ya une
voiture de gendarmes qui va avant pau
donc ya des choses qu'on peut progresser
c'est grâce à vous ah ben c'est clair
enfin je veux dire quand on a bloqué le
premier camion en 2003 c'est ce qu'elle
complètement changé la donne à l'époque
on a publié les parcours vous disent
merci
alors y en a qui le disent ne diront
jamais publiquement y est le disque est
quasiment publiquement je pense à
quelqu'un comme au christophe cattin qui
était au fonctionnaire de défense et de
sécurité avec qui j'ai eu l'occasion de
faire des réunions d'animation public et
dans lequel il reconnaissait notre
contribution à
la question de sécurité d'agir c'est une
évidence quand ça se fait qu'il ya des
trophées des audi public des outils
gratuits voilà du pentest de centrales
nucléaires en fait c'est rachel de
transport on leur montre métrage ce
matin après la question sexy ils sont
malins ils devront tirer des leçons ça
c'est pas toujours pourquoi il faut
mettre des procès il vous mettant toul
ça c'est une bonne question c'est à dire
que abandonner alors je sais que ça
ferait en dire certains mais je pense
qu'on contribue nous largement à cette
question de la sûreté et de sécurité par
l'apport du débat public et l'art là la
remise en cause ce qu'il ya un risque
vital
aujourd'hui un risque est vital enfin je
dis je suis je crois que ce qu'on a
montré le démon de suffisamment après la
question c'est de savoir comment les
autorités vont ils répondre
alors on n'est pas des lanceurs d'alerté
au strict sens juridique du terme c'est
vrai on y parle des employés une société
qui annonce un problème dans la société
mais je considère malgré tout compter
des lanceurs dallaire on montre des
choses on dit écoutez et regardez là ça
va pas votre affaire alors évidemment on
est contre le nucléaire et on veut la
sortie du nucléaire mais vous proposer
mais de toute façon juste pour finir de
ce sujet je passe ça après de toute
façon malgré tout les centrales et sont
là le les déchets sont là ces transports
vont encore avoir lieu à un moment et on
va pas mettre la clé ce soir sous la
porte et va falloir un certain temps
donc à partir de là ce sens de la
responsabilité de la sûreté la sécurité
il est indispensable qu'on soit pour ou
contre le nucléaire alors ensuite sur ce
qu'on propose eux
nous aujourd'hui elle a pas de solution
miracle ce qu'on dit malgré tout c'est
que le premier la première chose qu'on
doit faire c'est la sobriété c'est à
dire que si on fait pas ce brille et et
efficacité en premier quelle que soit la
solution y arrivera pas bon et on a
devant nous de toute façon un mur
d'investissements gigantesque et quelle
que soit la solution qu'on va choisir le
prix de l'électricité va exploser
parce que on arrive à la fin de ce parc
donc ou bien on va vous à le faire durer
ça va coûter très cher ou bien on va les
arrêter et remettre d'autres 9 à la
place ça va coûter très cher ou alors on
passe à autre chose ça va coûter très
cher l'idée même de dire que par exemple
le renouvelable de ma se mettrait en
place facilement
c'est à du greenwashing c'est un an
renouvelable ton pour nous non
clairement aujourd'hui le renouvelable
est quelque chose qui peut fonctionner
avec des récits ya derrière une vraie
volonté politique de développer donc
premièrement sobriété efficacité
deuxièmement il faut des il faut
absolument cette politique ambitieuse de
renouvelables et pas faire comme c'est
le gouvernement c'est-à-dire traîner des
quatre fers quand il s'agit de renvoyer
de d'ouvrir des marchés publics ou par
exemple d'inaugurer lusine
d'hydroliennes à charbon en juin et de
10 en juillet que il se redit que des
scènes se retire fâché on est dans des
aberrations de fonctionnement du si
nantes et ses hangars magnifique qui est
évêque qui a été inaugurée il y avait un
ministre irlandais qui était présent il
n'y avait pas représentant national
français donc à un moment donné le
problème c'est qu'on a un discours
permanent alors des uns ou les autres du
gouvernement à discours mais dans les
finalement il regarde c'est quoi c'est
quoi le greenwashing
levé le mot shing pour moi c'est
vraiment
alors il ya un exemple typique tout de
suite l'andra a donc l' agence de
gestion des déchets radioactifs qui à
bure fin par bus à soulaines à côté fait
peindre donc une fresque sur ces ces
blockhaus de déchets nucléaires enfin
voilà là on est dans l'image pure de
greenwashing on est aussi le
greenwashing c'est aussi aujourd'hui les
pubs de danone que vous pouvez voir tous
les soirs à la télé dans lequel est ce
que c'est pas aussi de dire qu'on va
tous passer aux éoliennes que tout ira
bien qu'on va trouver de l'énergie
renouvelable mais compense pas
l'épuisement des métaux rares a comme on
va chercher les métaux rares les trous
qu'on fait pour aller chercher mes torts
tout tout doit se penser absolument jeu
je pense simplement que
e.on et on va avoir demain malgré tout
malgré que quel que soit le type de
société on a malgré tout besoin d'un
d'un certain niveau de consommation
d'électricité
non pas que le dieu des f que ça va
augmenter avec la croissance de la
population et c'est ça c'est faux et
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
le scénario s'est stabilité ou peut-être
même des croissances des changements
d'usagé hier que même si la voiture
électrique se développe à côté il ya d
efficacité énergétique qui existe qui
aujourd'hui se mettre en place avec les
ovations thermique etc qui font que de
toute façon il y aura pas d'augmentation
de l'ex-société demain pendant que cette
vision de grande augmentation elle est
pas vrai on va on va
on va stagner la question c'est comment
demain je remplace ses centrales part
des choses crédible nous pensons nous
que la diversification solaire éolien
donc et biomasse en partie peuvent être
absolument des seniors crédit ballants
après suivant l'ambition politique on a
le scénario négawatt tourne à celui des
retours on a plein de scénarios sur la
table évidemment ils récusent n'en faut
sortir ce soir du nucléaire parce que
c'est dangereux oui oui évidemment
faudrait sortir ce soir la réalité c'est
que malgré tout on est un type de
société aujourd'hui où on va pas sortir
voilà il va falloir ce mécanisme de
sortie le plus rapide possible c'est pas
trop tard alors le problème c'est qu'il
ya déjà des choses qui sont trop tard il
y en a mais quel exemple d'avoir choisi
leur traitement est aujourd'hui d'avoir
créé les déchets vitrifiés avis très
longue et c'est ça c'est une aberration
evian teint on aurait dû déjà à le faire
après
l'ensemble des critères que que tu
développais tout à l'heure quand on
parle de cette question des métaux
lourds recyclage des produits qu'on va
qu'on va utiliser dans les lampes et
c'est extra c'est à dire que les
filières de recyclage c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit de développer aussi en
même temps qu'on va développer ses nous
ces nouvelles technologies et
aujourd'hui c'est très mal faite alors
il ya des pays qui l'ont plus rapidement
développée que d'autres mais c'est très
mal fait cette question d'accès au
terrain moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
que ça avant un vrai problème après ça
veut dire aussi qu'il faut du
développement technologique pour
justement juin des panneaux solaires
aujourd'hui on voit bien que entre les
premiers panneaux qui était extrêmement
dévoreur de commandes de terrain là où
on en est aujourd'hui c'est totalement
différent c'est à dire qu'on travaille
sur des oxydes de fer etc qui est
aujourd'hui apports des romans qu'ils
sont nettement supérieurs à ce qu'ils
avaient avant et en étant beaucoup plus
propre est des scénarios de deux des dix
cycles de recyclage sont parfaitement
possible de développer le nucléaire
dean quelque chose de positif sur le
nucléaire
alors je vais utiliser l'argument
bateaux utilisés par l'industrie
nucléaire je fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
une énergie qui bas carbone c'est à dire
que la quantité de carbone produite par
le nucléaire est faible alors elle est
pas nul comme certains essayent de le
dire en permanence parce que
l'extraction les transports la
conversion les indiana et c'est tout ça
voilà le premier producteur ces odeurs
normandie c'est une usine de la hague
parce qu'ils bouffent du fioul lourd
tous les jours pour le process ça sert
pas 100 mais donc yaya aussi il ya aussi
du co2 simplement de fait ça reste
faible on est dans des niveaux comparé à
vos énergies fossiles qui fait donc
c'est un argument positif après le
problème c est ce que ça peut avoir une
efficacité et là la réponse est non
parce que aujourd'hui le problème
principal qu'on a au niveau de ce co2 ce
n'est pas la production électrique c'est
d'abord le transport c'est d'abord la
manière dont on va brûler des énergies
fossiles à côté on le voit avec cet
argument débile comme autant en
permanence l'allemagne a fermé du
nucléaire donc on a étudié on a démarré
du charbon c'est juste totalement faux
puisque cette produisent 10 fois plus de
co2 que nous les avons complètement je
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas un problème parce
qu'ils ont la dignité selon lui
clairement etc je dis juste que la
phrase le nucléaire a fait qu'il a fallu
ouvre du charbon est fausse elle la
diminution aujourd'hui du nucléaire est
largement compensée par les
renouvelables donc aujourd'hui cet
argument là il ne tient pas d'ailleurs
l'allemagne continue d'exporter
l'électricité etc ça empêche pas qu'ils
ont un grave problème du charbon qui a
falloir aussi qui le réseau mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que cette question du
co2 il faudrait pour ça et efficaces et
qu'on se mette à construire partout dans
le monde des quantités de writer
beaucoup personnes en ont les moyens de
le faire de toute façon et on n'a pas la
ressource énergétique pour le faire +
rhénium n'est pas éternelle elle n'est
pas partout et le coût qui serait
générée pour mettre ça en place région
test rappelons quand même un chiffre
enfin deux chiffres le premier écrit
cité dans le monde le nucléaire c'est
que 10 %
il ya 15 ans c'était 18% ça ne fait que
diminuer le nucléaire en électricité
c'est 10%
mais si vous prenez en énergie est le
problème il est un problème d'énergie
globale ce qui fait le problème
climatique ça problèmes énergétiques
c'est pas prêt
électrique simplement c'est nos
déplacements et ses stars si on prend
les problèmes énergie le nucléaire c'est
2 % d'énergie jambon et au nouvel obs et
coup mais là on se rend compte que on a
plus de 400 réacteurs alors 452 allons-y
construisons des réacteurs pour avoir
l'efficacité on s'aperçoit que ça
passera pas ce que c'est tellement
millimes il a joué sur ses réseaux pour
dire une nouvelle c'est bien ça
représente combien des renouvelables
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
de chiffres si le média comme ça on a un
peu de farine ou non mais oui oui
absolument absolument par contre les
ducks et intermittents glace qu'on peut
voir c'est que le l'investissement qui
est fait dans le monde sur le
renouvelable gigantesque même en chine
dont on dit que c'est le sauveur un peu
du nucléaire qu'aujourd'hui et
l'investissement dans le renouvelable
est trois fois plus important parce
qu'on me donne du père le nucléaire
aujourd'hui il est en fin de course par
tous y compris même dans les pays où qui
pourrait être encore susceptible d'être
l'intermittence du renouvelable qu'il
n'y a pas de vent et pas dès lors tout
d'abord apparu seulement alors on fait
comment pour stocker tout d'abord
intermittence quand on entend pour le
renouvelable pourrait peut-être parlé à
l'intermittence du nucléaire au premier
c'est à dire que regarderont permanence
le nombre de réacteurs arrêtés voile et
je sais pas encore ce matin où on en est
et enfin encore récemment je m'amusais à
tweeté tous les jours qu'on avait à peu
près 20 21 réacteurs à l'arrêt sur les
58 on voit bien que la hausse iliad
intermittence il ya des pannes
régulières des entretiens réguliers donc
le nucléaire est intermittent dit que ce
serait une fourniture permanente c'est
faux on a une intermittence très
important dans l'univers ensuite sur
l'on n'ouvre un bruit intermittence mais
alors c'est pour cela qu'il va falloir
aussi aller vers tout un tas de systèmes
organisationnels au niveau de la
consommation qui vont aller vers des
quartiers avec des smart grid avec un
système de ou la domotique va jouer un
rôle important il va falloir aussi une
bonne méthode pour raccourcir la nuit
c'est d'avoir internet et des
interconnexions entre l'est et l'ouest 1
parce que la nuit voilà vous savez que
tourner moyens voilà les éoliennes en
mer il ya toujours quelque part
d'électricité envers du nord de la chine
et les chinois qui sont en train de
faire
ce réseau câblé un peu partout là
commença en france en france ça commence
aussi cercle rte edf et j'en touche
toujours su se tirer du cas où la
notion de que demain l'avenir elle va
passer par tout à fait autre chose qui
est avant tout la communication ça il y
en a beaucoup qui ont pas compris à rien
mais qu'on commence à comprendre et sait
faire c'est orange et que c'est un oeil
travail là dessus on aura un avenir
moyens seront une deuxième box soit que
notre box intègre à ça mais on aura deux
de la gestion de nos consommations
d'électricité par l'intermédiaire de
deux systèmes de réseaux intelligents
ç'a paru une évidence que aujourd'hui on
a un problème de ce côté là cette
fameuse pointe mercredi mentionnent tout
notre parc aujourd'hui de production
d'électricité en fonction de cette heure
le matin ou sept heures le soir et en
fonction du moment on a toute la clim
nous tous le toutou le chauffage est un
vrai problème il ya des gars semblent
deux pays qui ont compris on commence à
en décalé on dira mitshubishi vous allez
prendre à 8 heures on dit à toshiba vous
allez prendre à 9 heures puis je réponds
s'aperçoit que les gens ils démarrent
pas la même heure que les derniers
métros c'est pas tous à la même heure eh
bien on commence à se dire ben
finalement on est en train d'écraser le
système et au lieu d'avoir un réseau qui
est fait est une production qui est fait
pour la pointe à ce moment là on écrase
la pointe on s'aperçoit que la nécessité
de production elle va devenir nettement
moindres dont il nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps une dictature verte on
fait quoi on est un kaiser un autre tête
qui nous imposent des restrictions
puisqu'on n'est pas capable d'avoir une
conscience une prise de conscience et
ben moi j'ai l'impression ces couacs au
contraire la conscience et par chez elle
marche très fashion elle aurait marché
produite en mai sans l'adhésion des gens
ça ne peut pas fausser on fait comment
moi je me rappelle très très bien est ce
que tu es prêt à faire une grève de la
faim pour montrer qu'il faut prendre le
fit rien c'est une méthode de lutte
commune mais moi ce que je me rappelle
c'est 1983 j'arrive à quoi être conseil
municipal et à ce moment là on voulait
mettre en place le tri recyclage
puis tout le monde nous a pris pour des
abrutis du coup parler bon c'est pas du
bullshit l'ancien
il mériterait d'être encore mieux mais
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui le tri
que malgré tout une certaine efficacité
il ya des grandes villes américaines
aujourd'hui conviés tous de recyclage
extrêmement important et alors qu'ils
sont dans des villes de très grande
consommation chicago a une avance
considérable en pourcentage le recyclage
dans 83 tout le monde me voit qu'est ce
que ces méchas et puis et puis on l'a
mis en place mais ça marchera jamais
enfin ça a marché certes y'a un moment
donné on voit bien que malgré tout moi
j'ai énormément confiance dans les
hommes entre guillemets avec nos deux
enfants enfin je veux dire aujourd'hui
la proche que nos enfants ont de ces
problèmes là dedans les écoles la prise
de conscience est radicalement différent
de la mienne à l'époque et de nos
générations d'amour fait dire
aujourd'hui personne va aller faire sa
vidange de bagneux dans le ruisseau
voir alors il peut toujours avoir un ou
deux abrutis qui n'ont pas compris mais
globalement la société est parfaitement
capable de ce qu'on a arrêté de balancer
des boues rouges en méditerranée on
arrêter de balancer des armes chimiques
sous la mer on arrêtait tout ça non il
ya beaucoup de choses que oui oui il
reste des quantités de choses a
évidemment permanence améliorer il ya
des choses qui se dégrade en permanence
mais peut-être que je suis d'un naturel
peut-être trop pop this mais je suis
intimement persuadé que la prise de
conscience est quelque chose qu avance
on arrêter de jeter des déchets
radioactifs en mer pour en compte les
violences de pour ou contre la violence
a totalement opposée à la violence est
clair c'est un sujet très souvent de
discussion avec beaucoup de gens ça nous
a mis des foires situations même un peu
compliqué parce que l'expliquait des
gens que nous on pense que la violence
n'est pas je pense à notre dame des
landes des fois c'était des vrais
discussion de fond sur ce sujet moi je
suis profondément non violent je suis
intimement convaincu que la violence ne
donne qu'un avis mis à nos adversaires
pour permettre la répression on le voit
aujourd'hui à bure c'est à dire que
finalement des gens qui historiquement
était respectée et dans une lutte
extrêmement fortes ont été arrêtés chez
eux n'ont plus le droit de parler à
leurs copains simplement parce qu'il y
en a d'autres qui ont était servi
d'alibi
aux autorités judiciaires pour arrêter
tout le monde donc on est absolument non
violent et on nous condamnons toute
forme de violence par contre bien
évidemment des deux côtés c'est à dire
que condamne toute forme de
manifestation qui dérive mais on
condamne aussi évidemment la violence
d'état équipes d'ailleurs peut être très
violent ce sans coût je veux dire le
respect par exemple d'un débat public
c'est très grande violence lorsqu'on
demande aux gens leur avis qu'elle
arrivait aux fins l'averse
privé la france d'une deux de ces
industries un de ces petits dit parce
que c'est pas violent pour les autres
s'il n'y avait pas de propositions oui
ça le serait l'idée c'est bien de dire
qu'on a une transition j'ai pas
forcément le mot parce qu'il est
tellement galvaudé mais la réalité c'est
ça c'est à dire qu' il ya des endroits
où on a tellement pas prévu les choses
que c'était catastrophique rappelons
nous à la fin la sidérurgie les mines de
charbon etc du jour au lendemain en fin
de tournoi désert économique et social
et on a des situations catastrophiques
avec le nucléaire croyez moi ça va
arriver si sûr sauf que comme tout le
monde fait comme si ça n'est pas arrivé
eh ben on va être dans une situation
catastrophique dans certains endroits et
ça c'est un gros problème dans combien
de temps
là je pense sincèrement qu'un grand
nombre de réacteurs aujourd'hui âgée de
40 ans n'iront pas bien loin admettons
qu'ils continuent encore quelques années
c'est quoi quelques années pour moi de
toute façon le nucléaire en tant que tel
il est mort il déjà à bord partie moment
où les cours de production des autres
formes d'énergie est celle d'une classe
sont croisés c'est l'économie qui va
décider on voit bien que les allées
centrales qui ferment aux etats unis
aujourd'hui c'est pour des raisons
économiques et faire avant l'heure alors
évidemment la bosse un peu plus complexe
car gaz de schiste mais si on prend la
californie par exemple ces offres qui a
affirmé c'est pas pour du gaz de schiste
c'est parce que le solaire a
complètement explosé et que c'est ça qui
fonctionne donc ce qui tue aujourd'hui
nucléaire c'est évidemment
malheureusement quelquefois le charbon
ou le gaz de schiste mais ce qui tue le
nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est
développement du renouvelable et puis le
fait que l'industrie nucléaire elle-même
n'a pas été capable de se remettre en
cause de se renouveler aujourd'hui on
nous pond les mêmes arguments les mêmes
technologies des mêmes choses que dans
les années 70 ça n'a pas bougé
ce qu'on nous propose ce nouveau le père
au père mais c'est juste une pâle copie
de ce qu'on nous a faits dans les années
80 il ya aussi un mec super phénix et
superphénix s'était encore un exemple
parfait de la folie mais aujourd'hui le
second continue vous parlez la quatrième
génération la quatrième génération c'est
quoi ces super phénix c'est la plus
chère bouilloire du monde sait ça ah bah
oui c'était un millionnaire il y en a
d'autres on a des usines de retraitement
de rokkasho mura au nord du japon et
devait démarrer en 96 ans 96 grand
voyage de presse pour dire on va
démarrer leur traitement à l'heure où je
vous parle n'a pas encore démarré du
jardin glace et ça a c'est une copie de
taille mais qui n'a jamais fonctionné
qui voilà quelque chose à rajouter
comme je le disais moi en résumé je
pense qu'il devrait y avoir une prise de
conscience que on vit le syndrome du
minitel
nous les français on est meilleur
handball techno et tous étaient vrais
communistes hennebelle techno bien un
moment où tous les autres sont passés à
autre chose nunavut il le dire le
minitel c'est super
et on fait la même chose celle que tout
le monde est en train de passer à autre
chose le nucléaire est en train de
s'effondrer et continue de faire croire
aux gens qu'on va continuer comme avant
et une phrase fantastique était dicté
par la vie le patron d'edf lui-même à
midi on est sur un vélo si on s'arrête
de pédaler on tombe c'est extrêmement
révélateur ça coûte plus cher de
démanteler son nez on est dans la pente
la gerra se finit mal à mes nouvelles le
chien qui traversent la route vous
connaissez le proverbe c'est l'histoire
d'une société qui tombe et qui au fur et
à mesure de sa chute se dit
jusqu'ici tout va bien jusqu'ici tué
jusqu'ici tout va bien je pense que chez
edf jusqu'ici tout va bien parce que
l'important c'est pas la chute c'est
l'atterrissage
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
et jeunes générations on parlait tout à
l'heure d'été optimist d'agir
différemment je suis optimiste et je
suis convaincu qu'ils agiront
différemment je pense qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple on peut aller chez les
producteurs d'électricité qui sont pas
les élèves qui n'ont pas nucléaire en
par exemple on peut faire des choix dans
dans les banques dans lequel on va on
peut faire des choix dans les
fournisseurs excité vous et dans quelle
banque à moi personnellement
je suis pour le moment dans une banque
qui parle très peu faites ce que je dis
mais on vit avec nos contradictions on
va dire non c'est clair que là dessus
après c'est il ya des questions
d'habitudes de vie pratique ya des
choses que j'ai pas de langue de bois je
vous dis là il ya des choses qu'on fait
j'ai diminué la quantité de viande après
c'est vrai que l'histoire des banques
c'est un vrai sujet
non après voilà il ya des choix qu'on
peut faire chacun il ya l'engagement
enfin je veux dire
c'est greenpeace mais c'est aussi
d'autres d'autres organisations
séparatistes manger si je parle à sea
shepherd c'est compliqué parce que si
vous voulez paul watson étant quelqu'un
qui était dans les origines de
greenpeace et étant donc ayant quand
même mais on va dire un grand coeur et
profonde contre l'organisation comme sur
ta zone les relations sont complexes
après ils font leur part du boulot
10 km 5 qu'on a reçues tout la limite
c'est la question de la date de jus ce
qu'on va dans l'eau production qui dit
vous claquez 85 40% ou 50% de votre
budget ont pu le résultat mais paul il
énervé après nous donc qui continuent de
le dire mais c'est pas vrai
objectivement c'est pas vrai on publie
donc comme tous les ans vous verrez que
c'est pas vrai nom dans
fable j'ai dû voir que moi j'ai commencé
à être militant j'avais 15 ans j'ai
continué après je serai plus chez
greenpeace si c'était comme ça mais
c'est pas comme ça on est dans l'action
et on y est tous les jours et je veux
dire des gens ils comptent pas leur
temps chez nous fin je dire si vous
venez voir les horreurs qu'on se tape
les gens qui travaillent le week-end
tout mais ils s'en foutent parce que
c'est d'abord des militants sion et le
droit du travail le droit du travail
mais après on a le droit d'être bénévole
en plus sur veut dans les heurts voilà
non ce que je veux dire c'est que la
jeune équipe énergique qu'il pissait
quelques avec lequel je travaille c'est
que des jeunes qu une trentaine d'années
en dynamisme hallucinant et donc tu pas
inquiet pour l'avenir trois bouquins
nous conseiller entre avocats
conseillers voilà vous prenez au
dépourvu c'est quoi le dernier bouquin
vous avez qu'est ce que j'ai lu
rassam on peut donner sa combine un
playboy ça compte pas non non non je
suis en train de chercher parce que j'ai
en fait sur ma table de chevet c'est
presque toujours des rapports techniques
et là en l'occurrence je suis en train
de relire un rapport technique sur les
déchets nucléaires donc je suis un peu
obsessionnel nous dernier boulet l'été
l'été quand je lis autre chose de lui
des policiers voilà j'ai lu un bardage
voilà parfait yannick rousset merci
daria c'était un plaisir
[Musique]
e